in France astronomers have unveiled a  radio telescope that could reveal what's  going on inside an exoplanet it's tuned  to search for beam like radio signals  whipped up when a planet's magnetic  field interacts with the wind charged  particles coming from its star  astronomers suspect that a magnetic  field may be needed for a planet to  harbor life because it deflects harmful  particles from eroding away its  atmosphere in particular when the star  emits a powerful blast the hypothetical  planet on the right with a magnetic  field survives the blast the one on the  left with no magnetic field not so much  the detection of this radio signal would  add a new dimension to the study of  distant worlds